[Music]
welcome back to harbor unbox today's
video is one I wish I didn't have to
make but at this point we're pretty well
fed up with what's going on the heaps of
you have been asking why we don't have a
Geforce
r-tx 2060 review and since it's not
coming today tomorrow or even in a few
days time I thought I'd explain why that
is and touch on a few other things as
well so firstly let's get the art X 2060
review out of the way or the lack of
review and we were all well aware the RT
X 2060 was going to be announced at CES
weeks out it was really no secret to the
public and we were told was more than a
month in advance by quite a few industry
contacts so that being the case it was
well and truly on our radar but week and
a half before CES I reached out to my
own video contact and asked when samples
would be available I actually did this
because prior to emailing them I was
told by quite a few of the us-based
reviewers that they already had access
to the review guide that a sample in
hand and they even had the drivers and
had begun testing so I was a little
puzzled as to why we heard absolutely
nothing
typically Nvidia and AMD Intel they all
seem to ship samples to all the diverse
media outlets around the world pretty
much at the same time anyway my contact
replied later that day with well with
basically nothing we were told that
headquarters so Nvidia HQ had a strict
guideline this time and my contact was
not able to comment on unannounced
products concluding that you're always
on the top of our list and I will fill
you in as soon as I can
so what can I say to that I was
basically telling them that I knew other
reviewers had r-tx 20 60 samples from
Nvidia they had them in hand that I knew
that the review guide was out in the
wild and that I knew the drivers were
available of course none of these things
had been enabled on my press account and
I knew good and well that they were
withholding our sample then after four
days of nothing from Nvidia I received
another email asking me to sign an NDA
so they could rush out
sample so that seemed like things were
moving in the right direction the NDA
didn't mention a release date so at that
point I had no idea when the reviews
could go alive it was just one of those
sort of blanket NDA's it was to cover
all products and announcements for 2019
a similar to that one not that long ago
that created a heap of fuss
anyway I run over the entire thing there
was nothing unusual there these things
literally have zero impact and how we
review products anyway so I just played
ball and signed it that same day a few
board partners reached out to us with
their own NDA's for upcoming r-tx 2016
models so I signed away and these NDA
stand at the embargo I would be lifted
on the 14th of January so great I
finally knew and reviews were going live
also I thought three days later the day
in video was set to host their CES
keynote I received a da child tracking
number from Nvidia for my art x26 TFE
sample it had been sent from overseas
using the standard DHL service which
meant it wasn't expected to be delivered
for seven days which would land it on my
doorstep on the 15th a day after the AIB
reviews go live
that's certainly annoying but I thought
to myself well at least I have some AIB
models to review for you guys so there's
that on the 7th I watched the keynote
covered it and provided a video on the
channel detailing the r-tx 2060
announcement I'm sure many of you have
seen that after that I went to bed
because it was quite late and then the
next day I woke up except I woke up to
an Internet littered with hunty X 2060
reviews at this point it was pretty
clear Nvidia had screwed us and
unfortunately not for the first time
Nvidia seemed very reluctant to include
us in their initial round of r-tx 20 80
and 20 atti reviews they only provided
us with a 20 80 at first while others
got both we didn't get the 20 80 TI in
time for testing so we were forced to
use an AIB model which we were able to
source last minute Nvidia also held back
on giving us access to the driver again
I had to get this from another source
Nvidia did eventually give us access but
it was so delayed that without sourcing
it ourselves a review would have been
severely compromised the exact same
thing happened for the RT X 27 t release
we've got
ofE model a day after reviews went live
thankfully once again we were able to
source a bored partner model in time so
we could present you guys with a
detailed day 1 review but it was a
massive runaround that almost didn't
work out it seems in video wasn't that
impressed with our lukewarm reception of
the r-tx range because back when were
raving about the value performance and
efficiency of Pascal they were throwing
the things at us left right and center
we even got a pair of Titan X cards
though they decided not to send the
Titan XP version after we mocked the
value of the Titan hmm perhaps it was
around that time that the relationship
started to fall apart
whatever the case in video is more than
willing to work with us when we were
providing positive g-force 10 series
coverage and for the 10 to 15 years
prior to that we also seemed to get
along pretty well anyway jumping back to
the RT X 2060 situation yesterday I
fired off a rather irate email to my own
video contact and in return I got a
fairly typical response they understood
our frustration and they said it was
definitely not their intention to block
us from reviewing the r-tx 2060 they
went on to say that the first round of
reviews or the first round of samples
were very limited they didn't have very
many boards on hand and HQ tried to send
us one as soon as possible that was
pretty much the entire response at this
point there's probably a few of you
watching this video thinking that I'm
being all salty because I didn't get a
sample and well to you I'd say yeah yeah
I'm pretty pissed off are we entitled to
a review sample no not really
that said we have a long working history
with Nvidia and they do to assure us
that we were on their list and therefore
we would be getting a sample I guess you
could say we are still getting a sample
so they kind of got me on a technicality
there obviously I'm frustrated due to
the total lack of communication and then
the generic sponsors that followed I
also write for text button have been
doing so for a decade now and in that
time in video has enjoyed a lot of
positive content at techspot of course
some negative content as well but
overall mostly positive as their
products have been mostly good so should
I just accept
they weren't enough RTX 20 60 samples to
go around and we were just unlucky that
we missed out and there was no other
real reason for why we missed out it's
not because we provide honest content
that's in no way sugar-coated at first I
thought maybe it was just an issue with
the Australian samples we've seen that
kind of thing in the past where the
Australian samples get delayed just
because well where we are located on
planet earth so maybe that was the issue
but yeah that that theory didn't really
pan out because the boys over at week
Town who are based in Australia they
managed to get their hands on a sample
and their review although it was quite
brief they did manage to get it out on
time so I wonder why a video was able to
get a sample after tweak town ahead of
their release but not harbour unboxed
and techspot well taking a quick look at
their r-tx content so far we see that
they haven't given a single card less
than a 93 percent overall score the r-tx
20 atti for example was given 100
percent so generally they have given the
cards extremely positive reviews of
course they are 100% entitled to their
own opinion and they can review products
as they see fit I'm not attacking tweak
town here I'm merely trying to work out
why own video decided to get them a
sample and not us because let's be real
for a second there isn't a shortage of
these things if they wanted to send us
one for a review they certainly would oh
and before I forget we do have the same
sort of score based conclusion thing at
Tech spot not really a fan of it and I'm
not in charge of putting it together I
just do the benchmarks and give my
opinion but I understand why Tech's spot
include it because it seems like quite a
few readers do appreciate the score on
summary
anyway the scores meant to be a
reflection of my own opinion the 2080 -
I was given an 80 out of a hundred which
i think is fair enough and the 20 idea
was given 70 out of 100 which I also
think is fair the 27 he wasn't given a
score must have forgotten about the
scoring system on that one but if the
2080 was given us 70 then that would
seem appropriate for the 2070 anyway
this leaves us in a bit of a tough
position we provide honest reviews and
it seems because of that we're now
getting denied samples we just can't
compete with reviewers giving
over 90% for everything I think our
g-force RGX coverage was extremely fair
and it seems to be in line with what
you'll read and hear from other trusted
sources the 2080 Ti is an incredibly
impressive product in terms of
performance but at an MSRP of $1,000
u.s. and still a current market price of
$1,300 u.s. I'm certainly not going to
tell you to seriously just buy it I've
said it multiple times now the Artie
x-series isn't bad
it just isn't great either it's a small
step forward from what we had over two
years ago now the RDX 2080 for example
cost the same amount as the twenty atti
performance is single digits better
overall and thus far in video can shove
ray-tracing where you can't see rays
cast ray tracing will likely be awesome
in a few generations time but paying a
ridiculous premium for it now just
simply isn't worth it on that note
in video recently reached out to Tim
after his coverage of rage racing in
battlefield 5 and he had a pretty robust
hour-long conversation with the team in
the u.s. that covered all sorts of
things while NVIDIA did want to have
their say on RT X and perhaps clarify a
few things in our coverage Nvidia
repeatedly said that our coverage was
fair and reasonable and in general they
didn't have any issues with our RT X
videos in fact the team over in the u.s.
said they were interested in working
more closely with harbor unboxed and
techspot for future launches they felt
as if we were a little out of the loop
with necessary information to cover
these launches and yet just a few weeks
later and video decided not to sample us
an RT X 26 T which seems to go
completely against one in video we're
telling Tim over the phone
it's just a bizarre situation so where
do we go from here
do we persevere with NVIDIA or do we
just give up on them and use our patreon
funds to buy in video graphics cards in
the future and we've managed to grow our
patreon account quite substantially over
the past year and this has allowed us to
buy quite a few Intel CPUs as they don't
sample locked parts or low-end models
it's not something they do just for us
it's something they seem to do for
everyone it's been that way for as long
as I can remember so yeah we just make
do by buying our own
and we're now getting to the point where
it's feasible to buy in video graphics
cards so this is something we will
seriously consider without question
missing out on day one coverage yeah
it'll be disappointing and I know many
of you look forward to our day 1 content
but waiting a week for in-depth gaming
comparisons is I think something that
most of you will be willing to do
ideally we would like to work closely
with in-video to ensure we can provide
independent reviews as soon as possible
but getting shafted last minute stops
being fun real fast anyway that's the
story so far it's possible we will have
a big RTX 2060 benchmark comparison next
week with over 30 games just depends on
when we get our sample and obviously we
can't buy anything till the 15th of
course none of this will impact how we
evaluate in video products moving
forward it might delay publishing but it
won't sway our opinion one way or the
other
as always we work for you guys and
that's never gonna change
finally I would just like to personally
thank everyone who's left a comment
supporting us saying they're missing our
review and they'll be holding off with
any purchases until we can provide a
detailed review it really is touching to
read so many positive comments the
community support is always amazing and
I promise I won't let you guys down
thanks for watching I'm your host Steve
I catch again soon
[Music]